[Music]
foreign
welcome back to True News with me your
host true Geordie and this is the news
for the most part obviously some of it
will be made up because it's the news
now we've got lizzo in the news for all
of the wrong reasons her Battle of
dancers have come forward and are now
suing her let me get this right what are
they sewinger for sexual harassment and
creating a hostile work environment
you're done you are so done Liz or you
and your bingo Wings we're gonna cook
you in the alleged lawsuit the 35 year
old singer Beret at a dancer over their
weight gain sorry podcast she pressured
her dancers to participate in a sex show
while on a trip to Amsterdam inviting
cast members to take turn touching the
nude performers well well well I think
we'll see what we've got more minutes
here a dirty little Predator well big
Predator is that what you're into is it
oh you get your kicks they want to go to
a Chip and Dale show Magic Mike and
treat men like sex objects we are not
that we may be chiseled adonises look at
me right I'm a Greek god but that
doesn't mean I can be bought no no no
the director of lizzo's documentary has
said she was treated with such
disrespect by the pop star that she left
her job after only two weeks boring no
one cares
next up I'll do another singer in hot
water it's cardi B who literally had
some water thrown on her on stage and
retaliated by throwing a microphone at a
farm who's now since filed a police
report against her trying to get a bit
of cash in it just get your content in
she's Rich you know you've antagonized
that she's reacted cutter I love the
game and now she may be in trouble for
this probably just a little slap on the
wrist in it but it's news and that's why
you need to know about it forget what
the politicians are doing think about
this in less important news we have
found out aliens are real so moving on
uh to the most important stuff what you
want a bit of detail oh
it's just not going to get the clicks is
it do you know what I mean the famous
people get the clicks aliens I don't
really know what podcast have they been
on boring no one cares where is he the
alien guy there is the US UFO
whistleblower do you believe that our
government is in possession of uaps
absolutely based on interviewing over 40
Witnesses over four years she has this
thing right this guy has all the
credentials to say that he's telling the
truth but we don't know what his
childhood was like was he touched I want
to know these things because if you had
bad things up and you as a kid he might
be just using this as his moment I don't
trust him another key witness at the
hearing was retired pilot David fravor
looks like an alien the controller told
us that these objects uh had been
observed for over two weeks coming down
from over 80 000 feet rapidly descending
to 20 000 feet hanging out for hours and
then going straight back up for those
who don't realize above 80 000 feet is
space basically aliens to be honest so
that's an exclusive on True News aliens
confirmed now that is definitely an
alien like they're here already
we've just got to prayer that they don't
want us but how do we know that that's
not how we got here in the first place
maybe they went
a gorilla or whatever and that's how we
got here think about it
imagine the aliens land yeah who's the
leader we want to talk to you we point
to Joe Biden they're like good one okay
where's the real leader where's the
warrior where's the guy who's in charge
no no that old guy who can't wipe his
own ass he's the one we voted for yeah
well the one who can't even finish the
sentence yes but the one who's got a sex
offender for a son yeah that's the one
if he was the winner who did he run
against you don't want to know it's fine
okay enough about that talk about more
important things top YouTuber Jimmy
Donaldson or his otherwise called Mr
Beast I'm I got why you changed the name
to be honest Jimmy Donaldson just
doesn't have a ring to it who's going to
subscribe to that he created a fast food
business known as Mr Beast burgers and
it went tits up big fat failure um
actually and the reason being is that
the resulting burgers that were created
by the company he went into business
with should it on your market research
and flip your own bastard Burgers but
he's now saying that the company who
created them hurt his brand and he's now
going to sue them for serving up a
subpar product now to be fair to
Donaldson as I like to call him he is
known for his philanthropy he does a lot
for charity he is a decent guy he's all
right really a lot of these big
YouTubers well we all know they're
Pricks but he's actually done a bit of
good in the world I wish I could say the
same for those damn Burgers though I
tried one
tasted like us but not in a good way
it's another day in YouTube land in it
what kind of problem is this to be
having with your life do you know what I
mean me I can't get an extra bin from
the council this mother oh the company I
partnered with for my massive Burger
idea didn't work
me these YouTubers and the first world
problems and now for what I'll describe
is this sad story Remy lucidi the French
darede double who would regularly claim
skyscrapers has fallen from one and died
could have been worse he could have
tried one of those Mr Beast Burgers they
were shocking Remy was last seen
knocking on the window of a penthouse on
the 68th floor which was 220 meters high
in the sky apparently a maid in the
building called the police after
spotting him she could have opened the
window and that was this week's True
News let me know what stories to cover
on the next episode hit that like button
subscribe and I'll see you on the next
True News
yeah
see you there
[Music]